if you were to take a glass beaker so
let me draw it right over here if you
ever take a glass beaker and you were to
fill it up with water
you might expect that the surface of the
water would be flat
but it's actually not the case and i
encourage you to try it you might have
even observed this before the surface of
the water will not be flat the surface
of the water will actually be higher
near the glass than it is when it's away
from the squat the glass it forms a
shape that looks something that looks
something like that and so the first
thing we might ask is well what do we
call this thing and this right over here
is called a meniscus
meniscus
and in particular this meniscus because
it is the fluid is higher near the
container than it is when you're away
from the container we would call this a
concave
concave meniscus and you might say well
if this is a concave meniscus are there
any situations where we might have a
convex meniscus well sure you could have
a convex meniscus if you were to take
that same glass beaker instead of
filling it with water if you filled it
with say mercury
if you filled it with mercury you would
get a meniscus that looks like this
where there's a bulge near the center
when you're further away from the
container than when you're at the
container and the and so let me actually
let me just label this this is a convex
convex
meniscus but it's one thing to just
observe this and and to name them to say
hey this is a meniscus this is a concave
meniscus but a more interesting question
is why does it actually happen
and so you might imagine this concave
meniscus is because the fluid is more
attracted to the container than it is to
itself
and you might be saying wait wait hold
on hold on a second here we've been
talking about how how water has the how
has its polarity it has partial negative
end each water mole each water molecule
has a partially negative and has
partially positive ends at the hydrogens
so let me write this down partial
partial positive charges at the
hydrogens and that causes this hydrogen
bonding to form and water and that's
what kind of gives water all of these
special properties you're telling me
that it's more attracted to the glass
than it is to itself and i would say yes
i am telling you that and you could
imagine why it is going to be more
attracted to the glass in itself because
glass actually has the the the molecules
in glass actually are quite polar glass
typically made up of silicon a silicon
oxide lattice for every one silicon atom
you have two oxygen atoms you see that
right over here for every one for every
one silicon you have two oxygen atoms
and it turns out that the the
electronegativity difference between
oxygen and silicon is even higher than
the electronegativity difference between
oxygen and hydrogen silicon is even less
electronegative than hydrogen so the
oxygens are really able to hog silicon's
electrons especially the ones that are
in that are involved in the bonding so
you have partial charges partial
positive charges form at the silicon and
then you still have partial negative
charges form form around the oxygens
form around the oxygens so these are
partial negative and partial positive at
the silicon and so you can imagine
what's going to happen at the interface
and let me make this clear what's going
on this
what i am what i am circling right now
that is the water
this right over here that's the water
molecules
and what we see over here
what we see over here these are the
glass molecules so this is the glass
right over here
and sure the water is attracted to
itself
because of the hydrogen bonds but it has
some kinetic energy remember these
things are jostling around they're
bouncing around we're in a liquid state
and so you can imagine all of a sudden
maybe
maybe this let me see maybe this
character this water molecule right over
here maybe a moment ago it was right
over here but it popped up here just got
knocked by another molecule had enough
kinetic energy to jump up here but once
it came up it came in contact with the
glass surface right over here this the
the glass molecules it's stuck to them
because it's partially it's partially
positive end it's partially positive end
at the hydrogen
what the let me do that in that green
color the partially positive end at the
hydrogens would be attracted to the
partially negative ends of the oxygens
in in the glass and so it'll stick to it
this is actually a stronger partial
charge than what you would actually see
in the water because there's a bigger
electronegativity difference between the
silicon and the oxygen in the glass then
the oxygen and the hydrogen in the water
so these things just keep bumping around
maybe there's another water molecule it
just gets knocked in the right way all
of a sudden for you know a very brief
moment it gets knocked up here and then
it's going to stick to the glass and
this phenomenon of something sticking to
its container we would call that
adhesion so what you see going on here
that is called adhesion
add
adhesion and
an adhesion is the reason why you also
see the water a little bit higher there
and when you see when you talk about
something sticking to itself we call
that cohesion and that's what the
hydrogen bonds are doing inside the
water so this right over here that over
there that is
co
that is cohesion so that's why we have
things why we observe a meniscus like
this but there's also there's even more
fascinating properties of adhesion if i
were to take if i were to take a
container of water
if i were to take a container of water
and just to be clear what's going on
here at the mercury the mercury is more
attracted to itself than it is to the
glass container so it bulges right over
there but let's go back to water so
let's say this is a big tub of water
i fill it
so
i
i fill the water right over here now
let's say i take a glass tube and the
material matters it has to be a polar
material that's why you'll see the
meniscus in glass but you might not see
it or you won't see it if you're dealing
with a plastic tube because the plastic
does not have that polarity let's say
you were to take a glass tube a thin
glass tube this time so much thinner
than even a beaker so you take a thin
glass tube and you stick it in the water
you will observe something very cool and
i encourage you to do this if you get
your hands on a thin glass tube you will
notice that the water is actually going
to defy gravity and start climbing up
this thin glass tube and so that's
that's interesting why is that happening
well this this phenomenon which we call
capillary action
capillary
capillary action the word capillary
it'll refer to anything from you know a
very very narrow tube and we also have
capillaries in our circulation system
capillaries are our thinnest blood
vessels or they're very very very very
thin and there's actually capillary
action inside of our capillaries but
what we're seeing here this is called
capillary
capillary action it's really just this
adhesion occurring more more intensely
because more of the water molecules are
able to come in touch with the polar
glass
lattice and so you can imagine we have
glass here if you also had it also had
glass over here and actually would be
very hard to find a something that's
that thin that's on the order of only a
few molecules but this is i'm not
drawing things at scale you can imagine
now okay maybe another water molecule
could jump up here and stick to the
glass there and then one just gets
bumped the right way jumps up and jumps
there and if if we didn't have a polar
container if we didn't have a
hydrophilic container well then then the
thing might just jump back down but
because it went up there it kind of just
stuck to it and then it's vibrating
there and then maybe another water
molecule gets attracted to it because of
its hydrogen bonds and then it gets
bumped the right way and then it gets it
gets bumped with the higher part of the
container but then it sticks there and
so it starts climbing the container
and that's what capillary action is and
it's not just some neat parlor trick we
actually probably use capillary action
in our everyday lives all the time but
beyond the fact that it's actually
happening in your capillaries in your
body that allows you to live but if you
have a if you spill something on your
counter so let's say that's that's a
spill right over there you spill some
maybe you spill some water as you spill
some some milk and if you take a paper
towel if you take a paper towel in fact
if you took a paper towel like this if
you if you held it vertically you will
see the water start to be absorbed into
the paper towel
this this kind of absorption action that
you see that actually is capillary
action it's the water going into the
small little gaps of the paper towel but
that's because it is it is attracted to
the actual paper towel